القاتل الذي لطالم بث الخوف في قلوب
الملايين لعقود قد يكون شرف على الانحسار
فالخبره بحسب الدين مال البريطانيه يقولون
ان مرض السرطان يتحول ببطء الى حاله يمكن
السيطره عليها
فمقارنه بتشخيط في السبعينات تضاعفت
معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه لمده 10
سنوات لبعض انواع السرطان يتوقعوا الاطباء
ان معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه عند
الاصابه بالسرطان قد تكون مضاعفه بشكل
اكبر خلال عقد من السماء الذي حسب خبراء
من معهد ابحاث السرطان فان التقنيات
المتطوره على وجهك احداث ثوره في رعايه
مرضى السرطان الى الابد مع امكانيه اجراء
مزيد من التحصينات في العقد هذا نتجاهل
واحد يرجع الى مجموعه من العوامل تشمل
علاجات اكثر فعاليات مكتشفها لعلاج
الامراض وتشخيصات افضل لتحديد وتعقب
السرطان في الجسم ونجاح تثقيف الجمهور حول
اعراض
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله اخبار طبعا جيده النسب الشفاء
تتضاعف في عده سرطانات على راسها سرطان
الثدي وسرطان
البروستات نسبه الشفاء في سرطان الثدي على
سبيل المثال ارتفعت من حوالي 40 الى 80%
وعندنا سرطان البروستات ارتفعت حوالي ثلاث
اضعاف من حوالي 25 الى اكثر من 75% كلمه
السر هنا زي ما ذكرته في تقريركم هو
التوعيه والكشف المبكر الناس اصبحت تيجي
للطبيب في اعراض مبكر اول ما يبدا المرض
وبلا شك في تحسن كبير حصل على مستوى
العلاجات المتاحه اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
تقنيات حديثه نتحدث عن العلاج بالاشعه في
السرطان يعني ما ابرز هذه التقنيات
المنتظره التي يمكن ان تحدث خلقه عني في
هذا الايطار التخصص الاشعه على سبيل
المثال في السابق كانت التقنيات الشيعيه
والاجهزه اللي بتعطي العلاج الشعاعي همم
خليني احكي قديمه او ما تعطي الاشعه
بتركيز عفيفه فبالتالي مضاعفات بتنشا منها
كبيره وما بنقدر نعطي كميات كبيره من
العلاج الشعاعي الموجه الان اللي بيفضل
هاي التقنيات صرنا مش بس حتى المراحل
المبكره حتى المراحل المتاخره نقدر نصوب
شغله بنسميها الجراحات الشعاعيه على اماكن
انتشار المرض ونسيطر عليها فهي حتى صارت
تعطي امل للسيطر على المرض حتى مع المراحل
المتقدمه في همم في همم علاج السرطان
وكمان ما ننسى قبل المجالات الاخرى زي
الجراحه تحسنت انتقلنا من جراحات اللابر
سكوب او الجراحات المنظار الى جراحات
الروبوت المتوفر عندنا في المستشفى
بالاضافه في العلاجات الاخرى كالعلاجات
المناعيه برده عملت ثوره عندنا في علاج
السرطان
[موسيقى]